literacy is the ability to read as well
as to write the letter at gentlemen I
now introduce began reading aloud to his
blind grandfather senator Thomas gore of
Oklahoma he began writing professionally
at the age of 19 when the first of his
23 volumes was published not only has he
contributed those but also many things
to films television library stacks and
academia he's continued to read aloud
with as much panache as any platform
performer the number one bestseller in
the bookstores right now is his newest
work 1876 that's the title not the price
he is the essence of literacy in our
time and with pleasure I give you gore
Vidal
you're often told how lonely the life of
a writer is but we're never told how
unknown Lee the life of a screenwriter
is to survive the screenwriter must
daily hourly cope with the megalomania
of his director the hysteria of his
producer and the passion of his star to
my prejudice I the screenwriter is the
unsung hero of the movies the st.
Sebastian of the La Brea Tar Pits and I
am happy to be here to do him honor the
nominees for the best original
screenplay
are thoroughly go Fellini and Tonino
Guerra for a mccord Claude Lelouch and
Pierre Luther Hoeven for and now my love
Frank Pearson for Dog Day Afternoon
Ted Allen for lies my father told me
Robert Towne and Warren Beatty for
shampoo and the winner is Price
Waterhouse Frank Pearson for Dog Day
Afternoon
unfortunately Franck Pearson cannot be
here tonight I have been told that I
must accept the award so speaking as if
I were Frank Pearson
I want to thank Sidney Lumet and
particularly his wife Gail for making
this possible